.
In this presentation, I will explain to you a method called
Complete the box
The wisest chin in this style is that it will succeed for any
Quadratic equation, which is actually a basis
Quadratic formula
In the following presentation or presentation following this I will prove
The quadratic formula is used by completing the square
But before doing so, we will need to understand
All about him
It really consists of what we did in another
View, where we solve the quadratic equations
Using the Complete box
Let's assume that I have the square equation x ^ 2
- 4x = 5
I will put this vacuum for a certain reason
In the last presentation, we saw that these could be
To be solved directly if the left side
Full square
As you can see, completing the box is a conversion
The quadratic equation to a square is complete, to be engineered
Add and subtract from both parties to become
Full square
How can we do that?
Well, to make the left side a full square
There must be a number
We must have a number here so that if you
By quadrature I will get that number, and if I have 2 ×
Number, get -4
Remember that, I think it will
It is clear through several examples
I want x ^ 2 - 4x + something to equal x
- a ^ 2
We do not know what a value is after, but we do
We know many things
When I squirt things - this will be x ^ 2 -
2a + a ^ 2
If you look at this pattern here, it should be
- sorry, x ^ 2 - 2ax-- this should be 2ax
This will be a ^ 2
If this number, ie a will be half-4, that is a must
That's -2, is not it?
Because 2 × a is -4
a = -2, and if a = -2, what is the value of a ^ 2?
Well, a ^ 2 will be positive 4
Perhaps all this seems complicated now
But I will show you the rationale
You look at this parameter here
And you say, well, what is half that coefficient?
Well, half that coefficient is -2
We can say that a = -2 - same idea here -
Then you square it
Ie you are squaring a, and you get a positive 4
So add 4 positive here
Add 4
Now, as we have done in the first equation
You have to know that you can not do anything for one side only
Of the equation
You can not add 4 to one side of the equation
If x ^ 2 - 4x equals 5, then when we add 4
Will not equal 5
But will equal 5 + 4
Add 4 to the left side because we want it
To become a full square
But if we add something to the left side, we do
To add it to the right side
Now, we've got an issue
The issues we solved are similar to the last
What is this left side?
Let me rewrite everything
We now have x ^ 2 - 4x + 4 = 0
All we did was add 4 to the sides of the equation
But we added 4 for a specific goal, which is to become the left side
Full square
What is this now?
What is the number that when you beat it yourself will be 4 and
When I combine it with the same output will be -2?
Well, we've already answered that question
He-2
If we get (x - 2) (x - 2) = 0
Or we can skip this step and write (x - 2) ^ 2
= 0
And then take the square root of both ends, and get x
- 2 = + or - 3
We add 2 for both sides, and we get x equal to 2 + or - 3
This tells us that x can be equal to 2 + 3, ie 5
Or that x is equal to 2-3, ie -1
We're done
I want to be clear now
You can solve them without resorting to completing the box
We can start with x ^ 2 -
4x = 5
We can subtract 5 from both sides and get x ^ 2
- 4x - 5 = 0
It can say, if I have -5 ×
Positive 1, so the result of their multiplication is -5 and their sum is
So I can say that these (x-5) (x + 1)
= 0
Thus we will say that x = 5 or x =
-1
In this case, this is probably
Be a quicker way to solve the issue
But the neat thing about completing the box is that
Always succeeds
Will always succeed regardless of transactions or
Regardless of how difficult the matter is
Let me prove this to you
Let's solve the issue
Tough if we try to solve it
Analysis of factors, especially if we solve them using aggregation or
something like that
Let's assume that we have 10x ^ 2 - 30x
- 8 = 0
Now, through the above, we can say, see
Maybe we can divide both sides on 2
This simplifies the equation slightly
Let's divide both sides on 2
If we divide everything on 2, what do we get?
We get 5x ^ 2 - 15x - 4 = 0
But again, we now have 5 in front of this
The labs have to be solved using assembly, which is
It is a tired method
But we can now go directly to complete the box, even
So I will divide both parties on 5 to get
Parameter 1 here
You will see why this is different from what
We have done it traditionally
If I divide everything by 5, I will be able to
I swear on 10 from the beginning but I wanted to go to this
Step up to make it clear to you that this
We did not receive much
Let us divide everything on 5
If we divide everything by 5, we get x ^ 2 - 3x
- 4/5 = 0
So maybe you'll say, why do we analyze the factors
By aggregation?
If we can always divide this factor
We can get rid of that
We can always convert this to 1 or -1 if we divide
On the correct number
But note, when you do this we'll get 4/5 here
If it is very difficult to use analysis to factor here
You'll have to say, what are the two numbers
Their score is equal to -4.5?
It's broken and when I take their total, it is
-3?
It's a difficult matter to analyze into its factors
It is difficult to use analysis to factor here
The best thing to do is to use the completed box
So let's think a little bit about how we can transform this
To a full box
What better to do - you'll see the solution in several other ways
I will explain to you all the ways because you will see that the teachers are using
All the ways - better put the 4/5 on the other side
So let's add 4/5 to both ends of this equation
You do not have to follow this method, but I prefer to put the 4/5
Away
Then what will we get if we add 4/5
For both sides of this equation?
The left side of the equation becomes x ^ 2
- 3x, without having 4/5 here
I'll leave some space here
This will equal 4/5
Now, as in the last issue, we will turn this
The left side of a double-edged equation is a square
how to do that?
Well, we say, what is the number we multiply by 2 and the sum is
-3?
Number of x 2 = -3
Or we take -3 and divide it by 2
This is equal to 3/2
Then we make positive 3/3
If in this example, we will say that a = -3/2
If we squared 3/2, what do we get?
We get positive 9/4
I took half of this lab, and I squared it, and we got the
Positive 9/4
The purpose of doing this is to turn left side
To a full box
Now, we do for a part of the equation, we have
We do the other side
If we add 9/4 here, so let's add 9/4 there
How do you become an equation?
We get x ^ 2 - 3x + 9/4 = - Let us see if
We can get a uniform denominator
4/5 equivalent to 16/20
We hit the rugs and the place with 4
+ / 20
9/4 is equivalent to multiplying
Spread the B5 to get 45/20
How much is the product of 16 + 45?
As you can see, it becomes complex, but
I think it's fun
Complete the box at certain times
16 + 45
See that it's worth 55, 61
This is equal to 61/20
Let me rewrite it
x ^ 2 + 3x + 9/4 = 61/20
Complex number
Now this, at least what is on the left side
It is a complete square
This is equivalent to (x - 3/2) ^ 2
It has been for a purpose
-3/2 × -3/2 = positive 9/4
-3/2 + -3-2 = -3
If this box equals 61/20
We can take the square root of both sides and get x-
3/2 = + or -
Square root of 61/20
Now we can add 3/2 to both ends of this equation
We get x = positive 3/2 + or -
Square root of 61/20
This number is complicated and I hope it is clear that you
You will not be able to - at least, I will not
I would be able - get this number by analyzing the factors
If you want its current value, you can extract it
Calculator
You extract the calculator
Then let me erase all this
.
And 3/2 - Let us deal with the positive image first. If we want to
We find 3 2 2 + the second square root
We will choose the yellow square root
The square root of 61 2 2, equals 3.24
This is a complex 3.2464, which will type only 3.246
This is roughly 3.246, and these were
Positive image
Let's solve the subtraction
We can put the entrance - if you deal with the second and
Followed by the entrance, so that we want the entrance to be yellow, for this
Cause you press the second button
If you press the "Apply" button, I have put it where you put it, we can
We change the combination to subtract
We get -0.246
And you can make sure they check
The original equation
The original equation was above here
Let me check out one of them
- Let's assume that we have--
If the second answer on the graph machine is
The last answer we used
If you use a variable answer, that is the number
Here
If I have a square answer - I use the answer
Which represents -0.24
Answer box -3 × Answer -4/5 - 4.
5 - equals
- This is some clarification
It does not store the entire number, it turns into
Fairly rounded
It stores a certain number of homes
So when you calculate it using this number stored here
You get 1 x 10 ^ -14
If this equals 0.0000
13 0 and then followed by 1
Decimal point, followed by 13 zero and 1
There are many zeros
Or in fact, if you get the exact answer here, if
You made an infinite rounding here, or
Maybe if you keep this root image, you'll get
That 's really worth
I hope you have found this assistant, any concept
Complete the whole box
Now we will expand it to the current quadratic equation formula
Which we can use, we can connect
Things to solve the quadratic equation
.